less than three weeks after hurricane
laura america's gulf coast is preparing
for
another potentially devastating storm
that would be tropical storm sally
currently gaining strength in the gulf
of mexico
it is forecast to become a hurricane
later today
before making landfall sometime tomorrow
likely in eastern louisiana
here's a look at some of the flooding
the storm has already caused in the
state of florida this is on the ocean
side of the state in miami
people in louisiana have been filling
sandbags in preparation for sally
and some mandatory evacuation orders are
already in place the governors of both
louisiana and mississippi
have declared states of emergency cbs
news meteorologist and climate
specialist jeff beridelli is following
all this for us jeff good morning to you
hey good morning tony and good morning
everybody i think it's worth mentioning
you know we're gonna be talking about
this becoming
only a cat one hurricane but we stress
that
just because it's only a cat one it
doesn't mean that it cannot be
catastrophic and the reason why i say
that is first of all there's going to be
nearly cat 3 type storm surge with this
system
and in addition because it's going to
move so slowly easily we're going to see
two feet of rain some places could see
30
inches of rain so it is a dangerous
storm looking at the satellite it's been
disheveled
and lopsided the center is on the
western side of all the thunderstorms
and that's because we have a lot of
strong
wind shear over this system but the
windshield could relax enough for this
to become a cat one and maybe even a
borderline
cat too but notice how slowly it moves
maybe moving 150 miles in just 48 hours
or so
and that is going to dump a lot of rain
and probably cause a lot of surge
because of the angle
that it's hitting the coast you can see
that counterclockwise flow driving that
water
into louisiana and mississippi seven to
11 feet of
deadly storm surge is possible so be
careful and look at that rainfall
12 18 inches some places seeing more
than two feet
of rain and that's probably the most
dangerous part of this in the atlantic
it is on fire right now we have five
systems
tropical storm teddy formed earlier
today
so we are on a record pace three weeks
ahead
of record pace in the atlantic pretty
soon we're going to tap into the greek
alphabet
that's just how unprecedented 2020 is
not just for everything else but also
for hurricanes thank you jeff tony has a
little teddy at home we're hoping
teddy's okay thank you very much i think
teddy's gonna head out
wait wait go back to him what did you
say go back to jeff please say the
things ted is gonna have to see
uh it's gonna be okay i think teddy's
gonna go out to sea so teddy's name is
is good local local disaster in my
kitchen is all
right that's all teddy's name is good
thank you jeff barrett hurricane at home
thanks a lot